あの、ガチでHIKAKINさんに褒められました
もうちょっとで出来るようになるからね
ポンツクツポンツク×∞
...
これは違うw
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
お前達
じゃがりこは知っているか？
じゃがりこ
そう、じゃがりことは皆に愛される国民的お菓子の一つです。
でな！今日は！じゃがりこをねとりあえず紹介するよ
じゃがりこ
まずはコチラです
まあ王道のじゃがバター
これはもう分かるよね
こちらも王道です
じゃがりこ　チーズ
これももう分かるよ猿でも。
これも王道です
じゃがりこ　サラダ
これも皆食べてるよね
こっからが変化球
こちらです
じゃがりこ　たらこバター
こちらです！
じゃがりこ　明太チーズもんじゃ
もう食ったことないよここら辺は。
じゃがりこ　シーザーサラダ
最初からシーザーサラダ食えよ
じゃじゃらしあん
梅こぶ茶
お茶飲めよ
ていう感じでね
頑張ったんですけどなんとか7種類のじゃがりこ集めました
でな俺には唯一の欠点があるんだ
そう
味覚音痴なんです
実は...実はほとんどの食べ物が一緒に感じちゃいます
僕はだから別にコンビニでご飯食べてたら幸せな人なんすよ実際。
というわけで結局こいつらもね名前どうこうあれど
所詮はスナック菓子なんで
そんなに違いっつうのはね無い気がするので
今日は！利きじゃがりこをしようと思います
利きじゃがりこね
じゃあ早速
まずは味、まあまあ味を覚えよう
俺、味がまず覚えれてない
とりあえず味見しましょう
まずはサラダから
ホントに美味しい
じゃがりこって美味しんだよ
じゃあ次シーザーサラダ
あーもう匂いからなんか違うわ
うーーわ　わかんねっ
これわかんないわ
じゃあ次明太チーズもんじゃ
これ明太子がもうガンガン分かるわ
うん、これ明太子か分かります
次チーズです
チーズは一番俺食うから分かります
じゃあ次たらこバター
たらこと明太子の違いが分からん
じゃあ次じゃがバター
あぁ、ノーコメントで
わかんないもんだってマジで
梅こぶ茶
梅こぶ茶は余裕だべさ
うん、梅は分かりやすい
ルールは俺が全部当てます
ちょっとね、イケるからね今日は。
俺がねやっぱねお菓子マスターってことを
皆に教えてあげたいよ
まじで見えてませんからね
ヤラセじゃないからな
そこら辺勘違いすんなよ
な？俺はヤラセなんてしねーぞ
絶対ヤラセなんてしねー
俺ヤラセ嫌いだからな
ガチの一発勝負だから
その代わり面白くなかったらごめん
よっしゃシャッフルスタート
早速当てましょう
じゃあこれで
これを当てます　これを当てます
これ当てます
じゃあいきます
もうマジねこういうのパッパといこうね
いきますよ
あーー
うめーわ
これはね分かるよ
正解は
シーザーサラダ
あーいぇいぇいぇYES
YES YES YES YES
シーザーサラダクリアということで。
じゃあPart2いきます
あっ！やばいやばいやばいちょ待ったちょ待った
これはねアクシデント　これはアクシデント
じゃ2回戦目いきます
これだね
これを当てます
はい、いい？
当てますよ
じゃっ　いただきます
はい
正解は
じゃがバターです
いやこれイケるわこれ俺イケる
はい、残り5個
どんどんいきましょう
はいじゃあ3回目いきましょう
これ当てます
はいはいはいはいじゃあいきます
なんだこれ
え？
これは難しいなー
はい、ととのいました
サラダ
いやこれは
今まで口に含んだ3つの味が混ざって
俺はこれをチーズって判断できな（ｶｯﾄ